Hunter Biden finding new ways to torpedo
his dad's campaign and remind voters how
his sleaze go unpunished the first son
filing a brand new lawsuit against his
dad's IRS all Hunty claims agents
violated his privacy by illegally
releasing his tax returns to the media
and Congress
and the suit argues that The
Whistleblower is quote targeted and
sought to embarrass him by revealing
unsavory stuff like this
Hunter Biden allegedly falsely claimed
business deductions for chat for
payments made to the Chateau Mar mount a
hotel room for a supposed drug dealer
sex club memberships
falsely referenced on the wire as a golf
membership hotels he was blacklisted
from and a Columbia University tuition
payment
for his adult daughter prosecutors
instructed investigators not to ask
about the big guy or dad when conducting
interviews investigators were not
allowed to follow up on WhatsApp
messages from Hunter Biden's Apple
iCloud backup where he suggested he was
sitting next to his father
how dare the IRS take issue with writing
off drug dealers and hookers one of the
whistleblowers is calling Hunter's legal
tactic frivolous meanwhile it looks like
the hunter drama is draining Biden's
Mojo one report claims Biden lamented
allowed that he might be dead before his
son's case would be resolved Jesse
I have a theory would you like to hear
it please okay I'll tell you later after
the show anyway here's a question
Joe needs Hunter to sue the IRS to keep
them from following the money because
this is about Joe what say you that's
exactly what I was going to say because
now he was using his son to get rich and
now he's using his son to obstruct
Justice this is a cover-up and you can't
say that Joe has nothing to do with it
his family is suing the IRS agents who
were blocked from pursuing him and the
sky Hunter you know the guy that walks
around probably with a pop collar saying
don't you know who my father is you mean
Jesse Waters exactly except my dad's not
the president that's Hunter Biden it's
now a crime to get Hunter in trouble
right you get Hunter in trouble you're
in trouble and so but this is what the
bidens do they indict Trump uh they
threaten reporters for covering
impeachment you know anytime you do
anything to the buttons you're the ones
that are in trouble and now they're
trying to bankrupt the whistleblowers
because these guys don't have a sugar
brother with Deep Pockets financing the
lawsuits these guys have no money at all
they're IRS agents they probably make a
hundred and ten thousand dollars the
last 30 years of their lives so it's a
strategy I don't think it's going to
work I've never heard of someone getting
caught for tax evasion by an agent and
then suing the agent for catching them I
now love Hunter Biden for this I mean I
hate the IRS can we do this Dana I said
I wrote down Hunter Biden has entered
the chat yeah you are welcome here I'm
trying to remember the IRS lady that
everybody was mad at Lois Lerner thank
you very much so remember the Tea Party
conservatives and they're like how dare
you like the IRS goes after people and
yes so this is exactly what
conservatives have been talking about
the other thing that happened over the
weekend is Biden allies were sending
smoke signals to the attorney general
Merritt Garland saying
um there's some distance now between
Biden and Garland which Garland should
welcome but that might send a signal
that you better wrap this thing up
quickly or else you're going to lose
favor with the president
have Liz Warren translate the smoke
signals judge should Hunter sue his
crack dealer for the crack he snorted
yeah because if you don't take
responsibility for yourself I mean you
got to blame somebody that makes sense
look look the the amazing part of it I
was looking at the complaint here's one
of my favorite lines said it before he
says Mr Biden has cooperated fully with
the IRS investigation give me a break
that's number one and number two Evy
Lowell says my client Hunter Biden just
wants to be treated like every other
American okay here's the problem okay
here's the problem this is the essence
of the whistleblowers complaint that he
wasn't treated like every other American
that the fact is that they didn't allow
the agents to treat him like every other
American so the the question is you know
there's does their status as
whistleblowers Shield them from wrongful
conduct and that's what Abby Lowell is
saying I mean you know this is wrongful
conduct no it's exactly why the
Whistleblower statute was passed to
protect them in this kind of scenario
whistleblower is supposed to uncover
government misconduct and they say it it
violates his privacy act the truth is
um it was the judge who on Earth what
was going on between the Department of
Justice and Hunter's lawyers after the
whistleblowers exposed the secret so the
truth is that uh The Whistleblower
complaint is is accurate and it is
appropriate under the statute the bidens
just want to make a thousand dollars
every time the whistleblowers mention
his name and that's just what they do
but you know what this is bigger than
Biden this is telling everybody who's
thinking about coming out don't you come
out you don't want to deal with this
Harold in The Green Room you said this
was the last straw for you that they
were done with Biden and that you were
going to vote Trump I was shocked
frankly shocked that you would say
something like that especially in front
of those children I have a slightly
different opinion of what I said the
look Hunter Biden uh is innocent until
proven guilty like anyone accused in our
country he has every right to file a
lawsuit against the IRS
and people have every right who the the
the filing is against to react and it
sounds like whistleblowers are reacting
this will conduct itself or play itself
out in a courtroom as a judge knows
judge you have commented about his
lawyer Abby Lowell before it'll be
interesting to see if this if this uh if
this line of defense is the right one
for Hunter it appears after which you
said judge and what what has happened
that this judge on uh was able to allow
the prosecution the justice department
and the defense Mr Biden's team to
realize that they did not have a meaning
of the minds about this plea agreement
that they thought they had achieved and
the fact that he's now been indicted on
one of these these things the gun charge
Mr Biden has and now it looks like he
may be indicted on something else these
are all lines of Defense as we know
judge so we'll see if it if it works or
if it doesn't work you know if this were
Republican Herald the media would say
this will have a chilling effect on the
reporting of misconduct a chilling
effect remember that everything would
always anything you a Republican did
would have a chilling effect no chilling
effect here we have the IRS
whistleblower who's getting sued on the
show tonight at 8. wow Ziggler that's
amazing
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now